hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your [ __ ]
why did you buy a dildo just for a
challenge I will not be questioned on my
dildo buying habits by you are dumb or
doll I will buy as many dildos as I want
as I deem necessary for videos in fact
in the next video I make of reading your
comments I'm going to have a mountain of
dildos just waiting to be used
oh I just realize the implication of a
mountain of dildos being with you oh you
exercise regularly I can tell what kinds
of regimen do you use to keep those boss
guns you mean these boss guns that you
can't really see under this heavy shirt
that I bought from Korea that has a
weird built in scarf thingy well I'll
tell you the exclusive thing that I've
been doing for the entirety of the time
that I've been working out this year has
pretty much been [ __ ] no not [ __ ]
that's not no pretty much exclusively
for the entire time of this new year
I've been rock climbing and I've
mentioned it at every turn so if you
haven't seen it then you probably
haven't been paying attention I'm that
guy from Naruto yeah but I haven't been
lifting way yeah but I haven't been with
lift yeah but I haven't been lifting
weights or anything or going running
like I probably should have been doing
I've almost exclusively just been rock
climbing because it's super fun and it's
a challenge if it's something that I can
do by myself and it keeps it interesting
keeps me motivated to keep going
although I haven't been going the past
few days because I've been very busy
trying to play catch-up and by tomorrow
I hope they actually be caught up with
my work but soon mark do something
really stupid but funny in 10 seconds
I'm done being your monkey Libra girl 11
I'm done hey Mark do you cook yes I do
in fact just yesterday we had a little
Oscars party where I cooked my mom's
famous chicken and dumpling soup
it's a popular request with the boys
here but I was really happy because I
made it in a huge 22 quart slow roaster
oven and I cranked it up to max I just
boiled two chickens in there I love
cooking because my dad was a very like
Kentucky cooker with a lot of lard and a
lot of wholesome recipes easy to feed a
bunch of people I've talked about this
before but this is actually my mom's
recipe and I had a lot of fun doing it
because I like preparing food for people
and my boys love the food I talk about
my boy Ryan and Matt they're basically
my children I'm a single father of two
but also I just did a collaboration with
Rosanna pansino the videos not out yet
it'll come out in a few weeks but I
showed off my skills in the kitchen to
show that I'm not entirely stupid at
everything I do just most of the things
and some even then I fail that you'll
see in the video in a couple weeks I
think it's going up 15th I'm not exactly
sure so see you then what is the meaning
of life what is the real measure of time
why are we here and how well this is a
deep question to get into you right at
the beginning of reading your comments
I'll go in Reverse ish order why are we
here does it really matter why we're
here isn't it more amazing the fact that
we are here at all some people like
spend their entire lives wondering the
why of things instead of just
appreciating the fact that things are
things because the universe doesn't care
that it exists that's one thing that is
very interesting that in my philosophy
of life is that when you're existing in
this place where all this stuff is
happening the animals of the world you
know the other of the other things they
don't care why they're there they just
know they are there and they do a thing
and some people would argue the counter
that we as humans are smart enough to
realize that we are life and we are this
thing that is kind of amazing and
interesting but at the same time in the
grand scheme of things humans
an insignificant ly tiny portion of the
entirety of the universe
that still doesn't care that it exists
it just does and because it doesn't care
it doesn't mean that it doesn't do
anything with it it just goes ahead
anyway so my philosophy on life is just
to go ahead and do as much as I can
influence as many people or as many
things as possible and try to leave it
better than I came into it and that's a
very simple philosophy and it doesn't
exactly answer everyone's questions for
the meaning of life and the real measure
of time is completely relative so that's
an irrelevant question to ask period
because time is completely wibbly-wobbly
and wobbly Wiggly so as to the why you
make up your own you make up your own
reason why some people it's absolutely
no reason why some people is very
specific reason why but what's important
is that it matters to you and what you
do with your life so carry that for what
it is and remember that I'm an idiot so
don't take my advice too heavily ah
mark what's your favorite type of dog
breed this one Oh
jumped on my bed that's our she's scared
to jump down after she jumped up on the
bed this pet she's getting heavy
this is chica say hi chica hello every
oh let me do this hello everybody my
name is chika plier I'm here to do
reading your comments bah boo boo boo
boo boo yeah Pete might be but I boom
boom he got dog mode hey she's getting
big
ain't no puppy no more to ask my first
type of dog breed anyway
that's what kind of shape I'm in in my
exercise regimen mark whatever happened
to best fiends have you talked about the
recently and I just missed it
actually yeah technically speaking it's
over but I did just get a picture I'll
put up right yeah
showing the check for the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital that me and Wade
presented from the best fiends team so
yeah all the money has been donated
through the appropriate charities and
actually everyone involved have a
certain amount donated to charity so you
can find more information about that
around the Internet
if I find a link I'll put in the
description but this event was very
successful it was super cool we had a
lot of fun we made some really cool
movie style trailers out of it that you
can find in the links in the description
below as well uh and it was just a lot
of fun for a good cause so yeah it's all
done hey what happened to your boobs a
late bloomer okay what's with all you
people out there judging me for my
shortcomings and don't make a short joke
you better not you ever consider taking
your improv troupe on the road doing
like a college tour or something of that
nature uh yeah actually I would if I get
a good enough at improv that I would be
able to take it on the road which might
take like over a year to be to the point
where I feel confident enough to do that
but actually the game grumps are doing
something similar to that right now they
rented out the Hollywood improv I forgot
the name of the theaters but they did
the theater locally here in LA and it
sold out it sold so many tickets that
they actually opened it up for another
night and they're just gonna be doing
live gameplay on stage so like if
there's people that are interested in it
then definitely yes we would want to get
out there and go maybe I could even team
up with the game grumps and do that sort
of thing like let me know if you guys
are interested in something like that
because that could be even more
interesting than say going to
conventions we could actually go from
city to city and do like a touring show
to give you something actually worth
seeing if you come out to see us so let
me know if that's something that
interests you guy I might I'm gonna help
put that together because that could be
something really cool so let me know hey
mark this is kind of serious but how
would you deal with depression if you
were too scared to tell anyone if you're
scared to say that doesn't speak well
for your support group or immediate
family and friends around you you need
to be brave in these circle
stances and it's easy for me to say of
course to sell someone with depression
to be brave but reaching out to other
people is actually the best thing that
you could do and if you feel like if you
reach out to your friends they're gonna
scorn you for it and that's not a good
sign of your friends the real friends
and the real people who will be there
for you are those who are gonna support
you no matter what who are gonna believe
you when you say you need help who are
gonna go out on a limb to try to help
you when you're in need and even if you
don't go to friends and family speak to
someone that you can speak to
professionally or privately or someone
that you can trust with certain things
and these issues and someone who can
professionally deal with this so you can
get the help the most important thing
about depression is not suffering
through it alone so if you can and
anyone else out there that's suffering
please please be brave enough to talk to
someone about it
rights massive amounts of fanfiction
okay two can play at this game since all
of you seem to be so sassy today imagine
I'm right now I'm gonna actually open up
notepad here I'm gonna write this
alright Danielle who burr who Hoover
walked into the dusty nightclub no
action had been seen there in years she
looks up at the lone figure at the bar
shocked filled her face s as she
marveled marveled at the stunning visit
of Adam Sandler
standing at the bar their eyes drunk in
each other's they knew that it was love
at first glance they didn't speak who
were her and hey suddenly started making
out I am every
they got married later and had a
bajillion kids because da that's totes
adorbs see that's that's fanfiction
right in there that's what you guys
write so there take some of that haha
I'm gonna pop load that to fanfiction
org or whatever the website is and
that's gonna be your fanfiction Danielle
that's gonna be yours but do you like it
okay mark don't molest your dining table
I know it's legs are sexy but the table
can't help how it was made
hey what I do with my dining table is
completely consensual and we are just
watch this I'm sorry I made you watch
that and yes I had the slightest
sandwich style threesome with mud tables
don't judge me I'm tired of everyone
judging how I love every time Wade is
here mark acts the best ever I love this
it's my favorite thing ever and it's
really cool to have my buddies here I
mean Ryan and Matt do help me out with a
lot of things but a Wade is one of my
oldest friends and I can't wait to get
Bob and Wade out here so that we can all
do stuff together and have a lot of fun
doing videos and sketches and video game
play playthrough Let's Plays having my
friends around motivates me to do so
much more I mean on a daily basis I do a
lot to try to keep open my videos but
when I have my friends here I want to
spend every hour of every day making
cool stuff showing them the cool things
around la just having fun with them
being able to hang out with them and
just like try new and different and
weird things in videos like that's fun
to me and it always inspires something
new in
a new channel meme gets made every once
in a while and it's just fun and I love
having my friends out here and you know
I do miss them out in the other parts of
the country that they are but you know
whenever they're around I feel inspired
more than ever to do cool things but I
will not let that flame die just because
they're not here in fact now that
they're gone I actually am going to get
caught up on videos they're not gonna be
late anymore and I'm going to get
started on so many cool new things I've
got collaborations working with other
people in the works and I've got other
big projects like the thing that I'm
working with Ryan and Matt that I can't
toll too many details around and even
more cool stuff in the background that
you're gonna see very soon so just thank
you everybody for giving me the
opportunity because that's really the
heart of it all we wouldn't be able to
do this I mean we'd still hang out and
be stupid but we wouldn't be able to
make something big and phenomenal and
maybe a little bit stupid but make
something cool
without you guys so thank you for being
there for us and thank you for helping
us do these things yes that's what it's
all okay so that's all the time for
reading your comments this week thank
you everybody so much for watching
remember in the comments you can tell me
anything that you want for profound
silly I will try my best to read them or
as many as I can this way way a lot of
comments but also remember let me know
what you think about a touring show an
improv show music show who knows what it
could be but thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye bye